because you can either win or learn in a
design sprint
your next steps are going to vary now
it's likely that you receive feedback
from users about how they use the
product
and what they didn't like in this case
you'll need to reconsider some user
flows
or you might need to make some small
adjustments in the user interface
such as clarifying user actions or
making particular buttons and links more
prominent
if you received critical feedback about
the value proposition
or if users are not clear on what they
can do with the product then you should
revisit the original idea
you might alter the original idea or
validate the product
solves the user's problem entrepreneurs
see these moments as learning
opportunities
so don't feel like this type of moment
is a setback if you receive mostly
positive feedback then you need to
monitor metrics and continue to improve
your product
as you get more feedback on the product
you can add more features and fine-tune
the user experience
you'll see examples of this and learn
about metrics in the next lesson